♪ ♪
>> Greg: ACCORDING TO THE
HILL, THE NEWSPAPER, NOT THE
RAISED AREA OF LAND, DEMOCRATS
THINK THEIR NEXT NOMINEE NEED
NOT BE LIKABLE.
HE OR SHE JUST NEEDS TO WIN.
WHICH IS FUNNY.
IT'S NOT LIKE HILLARY LOST
BECAUSE OF HER SPARKLING
PERSONALITY.
BACK PAIN IS MORE APPEALING.
THEY WANT A FIGHTER, SOMEONE WHO
CAN THROW PUNCHES INSTEAD OF
RETREATING TO GWYNETH PALTROW'S
FLAT.
A FIGHTER IS IMPOLITE OR
NORMAL -- AGGRESSIVE, BLUNT AND
SOMETIMES RUDE.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THEIR TRUMP
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THEIR TRUM
TRUMP.
WE MAY NEVER RETURN TO THE WAY
THINGS WERE BEFORE TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO TIE THE
PERFECT WINS OR OR MAKE THE MOST
TASTEFUL TOAST.
YOU HAVE TO BE INTERESTING,
FUNNY, ROB.
IT SEEMS THAT LIKABILITY MEANS
LESS WHEN ASSESSING
EFFECTIVENESS.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO LIKE TRUMP TO
ADMIT HE'S DOING A GOOD JOB SO
FAR.
THE WAY TRUMP HANDLED TILLERSON,
THAT LACKED APPEAL.
HIS APPROACH CAN MAKE YOU WINCE.
THE RENEWAL OF THE MILITARY, THE
DECIMATION OF VICES, THAT OFFER
SOME OPTIMISM.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE THE BOSS
TO ADMIT THE COMPANY IS DOING
OKAY.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS MAY BE TIME TO
NOMINATE AN ADULT WITH AN ACTUAL
PLAN, NOT SIMPLY A CALL FOR HOPE
AND CHANGE OR AN UNDERGRADUATE
RELIANCE ON IDENTITY POLITICS.
ENGLISH IS NO COURSE OF ACTION
WHICH EXPENDS WHY MOST PLACES,
YOU FIND A DEMOCRATIC CHARGE.
YOU AN UNHOLY MESS.
JUAN, DO YOU AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING I HAD TO SAY?
DO DEMOCRATS NEED THEIR
CORRELATION TO TRUMP?
THEY NEED THEIR TRUMP.
>> Juan: DO YOU MEAN A
CELEBRITY?
>> Greg: SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
ADHERE TO THE TRADITIONAL MODE
OF POLITICIAN.
MAYBE THEIR TRUMP WAS ALREADY
BARACK OBAMA.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
THAT'S HOW WE HAVE DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: WE ARE IN A MOMENT
WHERE YOU HAVE TO BE A CULTURAL
PHENOMENON IN ORDER TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY, THAT DOESN'T SPEAK
WELL TO THE PARTIES OR STRUCTURE
WELL TO THE PARTIES OR STRUCTUR
STRUCTURE.
TO MY MIND, THE BIG THING IS
HERE ESPECIALLY AFTER THE CONOR
LAMB APPARENT VICTORY IN
PENNSYLVANIA IS THAT IF THE NEXT
ELECTION IS A REFERENDUM ON
TRUMP, TRUMP LOSERS.
YOU NEED A DEMOCRAT WHO CAN
ENGAGE AND BE A FIGHTER.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT.
GOING BACK TO GEORGE W, PEOPLE
SAID THAT'S A GUY YOU WANT TO
HAVE A DRINK WITH.
YOU WANT TO HAVE A BEER WITH
HIM.
MAYBE NOW, JOE BIDEN WHO WOULD
BE AT THE TOP OF THE LIST OF THE
MOMENT, IS A GUY YOU WANT TO
HAVE A BEER WITH.
YOU NEED A GUY WHO WAS WILLING
TO GET DOWN AND DIRTY WITH
TRUMP.
>> Greg: JOE MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE ENERGY TO KEEP UP.
>> Jesse: HE WILL BE OLDER
THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I DON'T THINK JOE WANTED.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DEFEAT AN
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
IT'S ONLY HAPPENED A FEW TIMES
IN THE LAST COUPLE DECADES.
YOU HAD BILL CLINTON WHO WAS
EXTREMELY TALENTED AND KIND OF
CAUGHT LIGHTNING IN THE BOTTLE.
THEN YOU HAD JIMMY CARTER, ONE
TERM.
BASICALLY THE WHOLE WORLD
COLLAPSED IN GAS PRICES WERE
HIGH AND HE WAS A PATHETIC MESS.
AND REAGAN CAME ALONG AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE A CHANCE
OF DEFEATING HIM.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT
CLOSER THAN IT WAS IN 2016.
BUT THEY DO NEED SOMEONE WHO CAN
THROW HAYMAKER'S WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT IN MORE OF AN
ASPIRATIONAL WAY.
IF YOU GET IN THE MUD WITH
TRUMP, YOU'RE GOING TO GET DIRTY
AND BRUISED UP.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH TO
RECOVER.
ELIZABETH WARREN'S CAN'T DO.
KAMALA HARRIS, BOOKER, BERNIE.
YOU CAN'T IS DRAFT SOMEONE OUT
OF THE BLUE.
TALENT HAS TO BUBBLE UP FROM
SOMEWHERE.
IF I'M LOOKING AT THE LIST AND I
HAVE A WHOLE LONG LIST OF
DEMOCRATS, I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
WITH A SMALL AMOUNT OF TALENTS
COMPARED TO THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: THEY DID FIND OBAMA.
HE WAS KIND OF DRAFTED.
>> Dana: HE GAVE THE SPEECH AT
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION IN 2004 AND EVERYONE
SAID WHOA, WHO WAS THAT.
THEN THREE YEARS LATER HE'S THE
NOMINEE.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS DRAFTED
SO MUCH AS IN SOME WAYS HE WAS A
PHENOMENON.
PEOPLE GO FOR OPPOSITES.
HE MENTIONED BILL CLINTON.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HELPED
BILL CLINTON IS THAT HE LOST HIS
CONGRESSIONAL MAJORITIES IN THE
FIRST MIDTERM.
THEN HE WORKED WITH THE
DEMOCRATS PEOPLE WERE LIKELY
LIKE THIS GUY.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THIS CASE BUT
DEMOCRATS BENEFIT THIS YEAR
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE FACE OF
THE PARTY.
JUST LIKE REPUBLICANS BENEFITED
IN 2010 WHEN THERE WAS NO ONE
FACE.
THEY WERE FIGHTING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, NOT JUST ONE PERSON.
THAT CHANGES AFTER THEY CHOOSE A
NOMINEE.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, WHO DO YOU
THINK IS THE FEISTY AS A
DEMOCRAT?
>> Kimberly: AND MY OPINION,
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THEY LOVE TO BATTLE.
THEY DO TWITTER BATTLES.
SHE IS SAYING SHE'S NOT GOING TO
RUN.
HE IS GOING TO BE UP AGAINST A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
THERE WILL BE 15 OR 16.
WHO WAS LEFT STANDING?
I THINK EVERYBODY'S GOING TO TRY
TO THROW THEIR HAT IN ESPECIALLY
SINCE THERE ISN'T ANY CLINTON
FAMILY MEMBER BLOCKING THE SPOT.
IT'S KIND OF WIDE OPEN.
>> Jesse: ONE MORE THING,
JOHN KERRY TRIED TO IMITATE
BUSH, "I SERVED IN VIETNAM,
REPORTING FOR DUTY."
I DON'T THINK THAT WORKS.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO GO FOR
AUTHENTICITY.
>> Dana: HE TRIED IT BECAUSE
WE WERE A NATION AT WAR.
>> Jesse: AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANTED.
>> Juan: IT WORKED FOR CONOR
LAMB, A MARINE.
>> Greg: CONOR LAMB WAS CLOSER
TO TRUMP THEN PELOSI 30 KIND OF
SAD THAT.